[Music]
foreign hello there good evening you're
watching the Press preview it's the
first look at what are on the front
pages as they arrive it's time to see
what's making the headlines that's with
Moya Lothian McLean contributing editor
at Navara media and Annabelle Denham
director of communications at The
Institute of economic Affairs they're
going to be with us from now until just
before midnight
so let's see what is on some of those
front pages
this will hurt that is the front of the
Metro after the big Bank of England
rates rise and the expectation of a long
recession to come
similar sentiments in the express which
says there are story times ahead stormy
times I should say ahead the eye
describes what's to come as a toxic
shock for millions of people and the
country's economy as a whole
as the times tells us the rise is aimed
at heading off the worrying increase in
inflation we've been seeing in recent
months
and the financial times assessed that
despite the latest rise the bank doesn't
think the future Rises will be as high
as the markets has feared
and as the chancellor wrangles with how
to balance the books the telegraph says
that he's planning a raid on capital
gains to raise the money for the
treasury's coffers
the Manchester Evening News leads with
the highly critical report from the
inquiry into how Emergency Services
handled the 2017 Manchester Arena bomb
attack with the headline never again
the guardian leads with the angry
reaction of families whose loved ones
might have survived the attack if they
hadn't been failed at every stage
the male asks simply what on Earth has
happened to our 999 services
and the mirror focuses on one young
victim of the attack as eight-year-old
Safi Rose Roussos and quotes her dad as
saying she fought for her life but was
badly let down
while the Sun that leads with the
departure of the England footballers
wives and girlfriends on a luxury yacht
hitting for the World Cup in Qatar
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out all of the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us discussing them well
tonight we're joined by Moya lloydian
McLean contributing editor at Navarro
media and Annabelle Denham director of
communications at The Institute of
economic Affairs a very good evening to
both of you ladies uh thank you for
joining us here on Sky News uh not a lot
of Joy on the front pages it's fair to
be said isn't it on those front pages
let's talk about the front of the Metro
the simple headline this will hurt Bank
warns of longest recession ever with
biggest rate rise in 33 years uh Moya
starting with you it's pretty Stark
isn't it
yeah it is indeed I mean the headline
sort of sums it up that warning at the
moment that we're facing a two-year
recession and that it's meant to be
going on longer because of the recent
sell-off of government assets
um they think the downtown won't be
quite as deep as perhaps in 2008-2009
but for the millions of people who will
be impacted by this
um particularly Starkey the starkly the
10 of poorest households
um the resolution Foundation said today
are going to be particularly impacted
this is not good news and the rising
interest rate hike means that more than
5 million households will probably see
mortgage repayments next year increased
by nearly 4 000 pounds so house prices
in the last few years have been
astronomical but borrowing costs have
been low but now they are no longer at
those low rates people are saddled with
huge amounts of debt they just simply
cannot afford to repay there are a lot
of difficult choices aren't there that
are going to have to be made by the new
Chancellor and prime minister Annabelle
and they've not got long have they for
the next big fiscal event on the 17th
no I mean I think we're in for an
extended period of misery and what
struck me about that Metro headline was
the use of the word will let's not
forget that a lot of people are already
feeling immense amounts of pain
struggling to pay their energy bills
despite the energy price guarantee uh
finding the food prices have increased
to such a degree that they you know
struggling to afford their supermarket
trolleys um so this will hurt but it's
already hurting already we are really in
for a long period of difficulty and I
think you know the political
implications of this are really
significant because Rishi sunac may not
actually preside over any growth in the
UK economy over the entire course of his
Premiership and unlike so many prime
ministers he cannot blame what has come
before because for the last two years
until his resignation earlier this year
he was Chancellor of the exchequer we
are you know a very long way from that
predicted post-covered economic boom the
the v-shape recovery that we were all
hoping for in the deepest darkest depths
of lockdown um it certainly is not the
case that UK GDP is going to be passed
uh pre-bandemic Levels by 2025 far from
it
um and I think you know a lot of
questions will not be asked about how we
found ourselves in this situation blame
will of course be placed on uh our
response to the coronavirus pandemic and
also the war in Ukraine but I don't
think that we should forget that there
have been structural problems with our
economy for many many years now we've
had stagnant growth stagnant
productivity
um we have a tax burden that is the
highest it's been in seven decades this
increase in growth of the state
um even if this trust is no longer our
prime minister she was right that
successive governments had presided over
managed Decline and that is something
that wish you see like and Jeremy Hunt
are going to have to tackle along with
all of the other economic headwinds
we're now facing all right and you're
saying there that Liz truss was right
about some things but coming to you on
this Moya if it weren't for the
disastrous mini budget we wouldn't be
having to have this next big fiscal
event with undoing everything that she
put in train
exactly this trust tipped what was a
problem into a full-blown crisis and now
they're having to mop up the mess that
was left but what is interesting about
this is there is there's competing ideas
about exactly what needs to be done in
order to fix the UK economy for example
yesterday uh Larry Elliott the guardian
economics editor said that this black
hole this fiscal black hole that keeps
being talked about is essentially a
fairy tale and warned that the
conservatives are actually going to
repeat the mistakes of austerity in 2010
in 2008 there was warnings that raising
interest rates would cause a monster
recession but then in 2010 George
Osborne decided it was time to tackle
this so-called budget deficit to keep
the financial markets happy and what we
have seen over the last few weeks in
particular is that anything at any cost
it's about keeping the financial markets
happy but this often comes at the
expense of the actual public who've been
subject for the last 10 years to tax
increases and spending cuts which have
brought the country's public services to
Breaking Point and now we look set to do
it all again for this fiscal black hole
that is being talked about over and over
um let's talk Annabelle about the uh
about the Ft uh Bank of England takes
dovish stance despite biggest rate rise
for 30 years I mean when you listen to
what Andrew Bailey had to say it didn't
sound particularly dovish to me what
what did you hear in it that was dovish
no not much that was damaged at all but
of course this is in contrast to actions
taken by the US Federal Reserve and the
warnings from Jay Powell the chair of
the Federal Reserve that interest rates
over in the US are going to Peak at a
level higher than was expected and what
we're seeing here on UK soil is a
standoff between the bank of England and
and other institutions and investors
over the terminal rate uh essentially
how high interest rates are going to go
and the bank has today pushed back
against Market expectations that
interest rates could hit 5.25
next year the bankers and Andrew Bailey
the governor of the bank of England said
that they can't make promises over uh
future interest rates but he thinks that
based on where we are today the bank
rate will got by by less than is
currently priced in financial markets um
now I mean I think this probably has to
be taken with a slight pinch of salt
because you know Bank of England the
monetary policy committee have been very
wrong on uh inflation over the last
couple of years and indeed has the U.S
uh Federal Reserve both institutions
have called it transitory and we're
calling it transitory for for really far
too long long after it had become
apparent that inflation was going to be
a very real concern for many months and
years uh to come so yes the bank of
England might be more um dovish than
than the FED but it has nonetheless
brought in this uh 70.75 percentage
points uh rise is the largest uh for
three decades
um and I think that's it's probably the
right amount is bringing us in line with
uh the fed and the European Central Bank
um and the question really now is how
much higher interest rates going to go
not just here but in the US as well and
more just very quickly a final word from
you uh on on the economy do you see any
Silver Linings
no but I do see an opportunity for us to
really examine our current economic
setup if we're having you know three
recessions over the span of 12 Years
surely the current system is not working
as it's intended to and something else
should be considered
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me now are Moya Lothian
McLean contributing editor at Navara
media and Annabelle Denham director of
communications at The Institute of
economic Affairs
um we're going to switch gear now to
talk about the inquiry that's been
taking place into the Dreadful events
that took place in Manchester Arena and
a stark reminder on the front page of
the Manchester Evening News Moya that
these families have waited more than
five years to hear the conclusions to
hear that their relatives were badly let
down at every stage
yes indeed uh the story that follows
this front page is extremely powerful uh
it's it's written in it opens with the
words of Safi Rose ruseus which is am I
going to die which it was reported later
in the aftermath and it came out in this
report that this this is what she said
an eight-year-old child said after going
to this concert to see her favorite
singer Ariana Grande and instead the
slow responses of emergency services
this inquiry found meant that two people
who could have lived uh there was a
remote possibility that Safi could have
lived and that John Atkinson who was a
20 like eight-year-old care worker had
survivable injuries that both of these
people could have been saved was it not
for a series of failures in all branches
of the emergency services that were
deployed that night
um so this inquiry has taken as you say
five years in the making it's been
extremely traumatic for families who've
had to both relive the pain of losing
loved ones but also the push for answers
within this the story then safi's family
talk about again and again and again
having been pushed back denials from
Manchester Manchester police being told
that no nothing went wrong that they
weren't at fault Etc and now this
inquiry they say vindicate something
that they knew all along that there were
deep systemic failures within the
response of emergency services that
meant where people could have got help
they didn't yeah and the question is I
suppose Annabelle whether these mistakes
can ever happen again and certainly the
parents of sappy Rose are continuing to
insist that she would have lived had
those errors not been made
yes I mean that's right and you know on
the cover of the mail which I know we'll
be talking about later it appears that
some of the mistakes that were made
after the Manchester terrorist attack
were actually made after the seven seven
bombings so this isn't really a case of
you know this is they were an
unprecedented circumstances Emergency
Services perhaps haven't been tested to
this extent before but we now no
mistakes were made and we will learn
from them because this has happened in
the past and the mistakes have been uh
repeated and there are so many avoidable
errors that appear to have been made uh
the fact that nobody declared a major
incident